so um
so that this this uh
this is eric you are a a
cardiologist a geneticist a teacher
a
geek a entrepreneur
but one of the things that i wanted to
talk to you about
and an author i should mention the the
creative destruction of medicine um one
of the things that i wanted to
talk about right out the outside since
since craig was just talking about this
um
you were one of the first people or
among the first cohort of physicians
practicing physicians to recognize that
there was this this turn in the way
genetics was used so the traditional use
of genetics in medicine was these kind
of tests for for deterministic
conditions um and that's the classic
kind of genetic test that that we give
mothers or expectant mothers or or um
newborns
but you recognize that there was this
what the genetics that craig was working
on created a different kind of
engagement for um patients and
physicians with
their their dna and i wanted to see if
um i want to ask you basically was there
a light bulb moment for you when when
you kind of realized that
there was a way of integrating the
genetic stuff that that craig was doing
into your your practice well it really
was actualizing the potential for the
public consumers
uh that that just wasn't just only a
research play that in fact a lot of this
information could be useful and i
actually would maintain that it is it's
all part of this digitizing human being
theme
whereby people who know their dna first
these common variants and then as we go
on with more sequencing the low
frequency rear variants
that'll become much more granular we'll
have much more uh probabilistic
information about what each person's
liabilities are
but
early on we did a study uh with a
consumer genomics company
navigenetics like
23 and me and others that are really
catering to getting this data
out to the public
i think it's terrific and we did a study
in a few thousand people that showed
that they cope very well with this
information and in many cases it was
highly actionable in terms of getting
the right screening
in terms of avoiding
sun
all sorts of things that
whether it's diabetes or colon cancer it
it brought to the fore
important
information about their potential
susceptibility
so it's actionable for for patients to
change their
lives make different decisions based on
their genetics
who is who's responsible for that in in
kind of the current healthcare system
who's responsible for saying okay
let's do the test or i am going to do a
test
where does that responsibility lie we're
in a pretty
tricky time right now because the
american medical association for example
is lobbying the government that people
shouldn't have direct access they should
actually have to go through a doctor or
genetic counselor the latter doesn't
make much sense there's only 3 000
genetic counselors for 310 million
people in this country right so that's
not going to work as far as physicians
we know from surveys that the ama did
that only less than 10 percent have any
comfort level
in interpreting this data or using it so
that's why i think it's really important
that this is driven by consumers
uh and it's admittedly the information
we have today is is somewhat limited but
it's it's still in many individuals it's
highly worthwhile and it's just going to
get better and better over time and i
think that's the right of each
individual they want to have access to
their dna data that should be fully
democratized and so we're going through
a tough time right now because
governmental agencies have been
basically working against that theme
and i don't think it's a good idea
so so one the kind of most most um
familiar way of talking about this is
pharmacogenomics the idea of tailoring
drugs to people's genome which always
seemed like it was going to happen
sometime in the future but we were
talking about
the the fda has a list right now that's
available on the website
where there are 120 130 drugs that right
now have specific genetic interactions
um
so that list is there but what so so you
you did plavix i think is some some of
the work that you did specifically on
that drug that has specific interactions
i i know that i have the
uh the mutation or the variation that
makes me basically it doesn't work for
me that drug doesn't work for me but
unless i had my 23andme test i wouldn't
know
so that list who's who's kind of making
that list
bringing that into the clinic well right
now it's just sitting dormant it's
really unfortunate and there's only
select centers that are using select
bits of this pharmacogenomic rich data
so whether it's plavix now generic
clopidogrel or whether it's interferon
for treating hepatitis c
whether it's tegritol carbamazepine
which is used for a variety of
neurologic disorders and has a
potentially fatal side effect that could
be screened but not in this country only
in taiwan where you have to have a
genotype before you can get that
prescription filled uh that's a uniform
policy so we're gonna try to explain
explain that because
so in taiwan they do a test they have a
kind of it's it's it's by the law right
it's by law
and so you so the one in one thousand
people that take tegritol carbamazepine
who could get stevens-johnson syndrome
and die that's screened out by doing
genotypes even johnson syndrome is not
where you go and write books about the
invention of air and stuff no that's a
different stephen johnson on innovation
this one is a
horrendous uh immune mediated from even
just one pill a skin reaction that one
out of four people die from
so we just basically
give the drug we know the allele in
european ancestry in this country but we
do nothing about it and just one of many
examples on the list but not being
actualized in in medical care patients
so how are you how are you um so you run
the translational research institute at
scripps but you also have a clinical
practice there
how are you
and and how is scripps introducing this
well we're trying to get a lot of these
things into the real world of everyday
care so we did back in 0-9 to start the
plavix
story anyone who's having a stint gets a
genotype to see whether they'll respond
since one out of three people carry a
loss-of-functional allele it doesn't
allow them to metabolize the drug which
is basically inactive it's like taking a
placebo
so that's a pretty big problem which we
can screen out
and then work with either higher doses
of the drug which in some people can
override or switch to other new drugs
which bypass the problem
and then we
have also instituted the interferon
screening because half the people for
hepatitis c who get pegulated interferon
are not going to respond and you can
predict that very accurately with this
simple
genotype io28b
but now we'd like to roll this out for
things like metformin statins for the
the muscle reaction the severe muscle
range and many others that we have the
knowledge but we're not using it which
is really unfortunate right and so this
is some of the research that you're
doing at scripps is is built to making
these kind of pushing this thing forward
um the one that we talked about that i i
think is immediately relevant is the dna
electronics project right can you
explain that one yeah so one of the
barriers here is not just lack of the
knowledge but making it practical
because if you do the genotype and it
takes a week to come back it's kind of
out of sight out of mind and maybe a
different physician all kinds of things
that can get in the way so now if we can
do this at point of care in 20 minutes
or even down to 10 minutes that's what
we're working with right now with the
company dna electronics
and what we're hoping to do very soon is
to get that in local pharmacies they're
actually really keen on it because the
pharmacist can do the cheek swab do the
genotype that's relevant and then the
consumer can shop 15 minutes in the
store in the drugstore which they like
but in the meantime we can match up the
right person with the right drug right
those sort of thing and that i think
would be a big big advantage right there
um so the other
big piece of research that you're doing
so so that's so there's all this
genetics and we'll get back to the
genetic stuff but i also you you also
have this um
uh
the institute for
i'm trying to get the the the uh the
sensor center that you have
and
you've got a recent grant for just a
couple weeks ago from qualcomm to do
research basically connecting sensors to
the medical clinic and information
and i want to i want to help people
understand that kind of where where
again you're kind of taking this this
future that we were hearing about
yesterday from from gary and kevin about
quantify itself and you're making it
you're actually bringing it into the
clinic right now right so this is
scripps digital medicine and that's it
as you mentioned uh thomas we got a
great uh grant from the qualcomm
foundation right uh and that's important
distinction yeah for a foster uh and
accelerate some of these projects um one
of the ones that's a little more
futuristic is the nano sensor that's put
into the blood to couple with genomic
signatures so we're trying to not
predict heart attacks as was mentioned
yesterday uh with respect to
uh you know who might get one sometime
in their life but actually temporarily
know that within days that between the
sensor that's in the blood and the
genomic signature of cells that are
being shed into the from an artery into
the bloodstream that would be
basically sending a signal to a
smartphone and a special heart attack
ringtone would be sounding off and you'd
know days before a heart attack would
otherwise occur okay so let me just
so let's start with sensor in the blood
what what what is that is this is this i
mean this is not the pillar you swallow
how do you get how do you get into the
bloodstream well this is taking the
wearable sensor phase that we're in
right now to a kind of uber level of
being able to have a window into body's
medical essence because so much is going
on in the blood and so if you can just
inject in a vein in the arm
a sensor that's about 90 microns right
now we're working with caltech on their
nano sensor group it will then lodge in
the in a finger
and then basically that can talk
continuously uh powered by the blood
itself to a smartphone
okay powered by the blood itself right
what so is that like a hydroelectric dam
in your bloodstream you got it that's it
it's really i guess
you could call it that it sounds pretty
good to me it's a power it's a the power
of the blood itself is basically
adequate for something that small to
provide
a power source so and and this this
sensor 90 microns there's not a risk of
that that getting into the heart and
causing a blockage or something no no it
gets down to a kind of watershed
capillary bed area so it really can't go
much further than that how do you make
sure that that happens well we're doing
animal testing first but
you know that there's already been some
work along those lines stanford also has
done a microchip floating in the blood
fantastic voyage they called it yeah
yeah so you know i think we're we're
moving in that direction that's a more
uh a a bit futuristic it's going to be
at least a few years before we can
really get that enabled in patients but
i think it's exciting because then you
could follow
free circulating dna continuously for
someone who's had cancer or is at high
risk you can follow antibodies and the
immune system to be able to predict an
immune attack so all kinds of things by
once you have that type of surveillance
so what is the i i just got to
understand this so what is the sensor
how does the sensor that sensor is able
to
i mean a genetic sequencing machine now
is is huge but this you're talking about
a sensor that's that tiny that somehow
can can be parsing genetic code well
that's basically an outgrowth of this
digitizing human being because if you
can get a genomic signature it could be
dna or rna it could be an antibody you
can couple a sensor today to a specific
signal and that um okay so it's
recognizing a pattern rather than rather
than decoding the whole thing yes
exactly
um so so uh so those are
very tiny very very futuristic sensors
but you you are also doing a lot of work
right now um with with sensors that are
are existing and able to be used um and
you brought some i did um so i wanted to
i wanted to go through some of those
because those are those are important
because they're they're actually
even even though they're not um uh
little centers that are using the power
of our blood in our fingertips um they
are very much kind of this step into the
future that that um is is this medicine
we've been talking about so i wanna i
wanna go through those
um
your choice which one goes first well
these are things that are using we're
using today i'm using it and certainly
in patients like when i see a patient in
the clinic i don't send them for a
cardiogram i can just do it on the phone
so this
has a couple of sensors in the back you
make a a circuit with your heart and
just pop it on the back of an iphone or
this little credit card version you can
use to get the chest leads you can do
all that
yeah it's really the live core right a
live core technology right and so you
just basically can pull up the app
for doing cardiogram put your fingers on
it
and uh in a second we should have a
cardiogram
and that's your
yeah that's my cardio you want to do
yours i mean i'd love to i haven't i
haven't done a cardiogramming year
so just uh and but what's great about it
then you could just set it up you know
if you were worried about a heart rhythm
that you were worried about now i'm
gonna
just put a finger on you're going to see
something and i'm going to be have to go
to the hospital right away or something
there it is that's good
good night see i'm nervous i may do that
was that run this morning with that got
a deep breath
wow that's not good is it no it's
actually a nice pacemaker normal sinus
rhythm right good see it's going down
it's going down it was at 90 and now
it's at 74.
come on get down to 73. okay i can do
this later
but this this so i want to there's two
things about this that i so one is you
um
you had this great story about when you
were you had that kind of prophetic call
on the airplane when they said is there
a doctor on board
and and what happened well i had never
even thought of using it you know thirty
thousand feet but when there were you
had it on you i had it because i was at
a program like this and was showing it
and then i realized that when this
passenger was having chest pressure and
i didn't know was indigestion he didn't
know it was into just
uh maybe i can go get this and do a
cartogram and actually it was this
this part that was the key because then
i could do the all the the so-called
precordial leads in my chest and that
showed a very classic pattern of
so-called anterior wall front of the
heart
evolving heart attack so there wasn't
any question what it was and that led to
getting him
to a hospital emergency landing he said
land the plane well i mean i did the
pilot of course wasn't too interested in
landing the plane but there was
objective
data that uh you know there's something
going on here that is the real deal
right but the interesting thing about it
was and he did well and they got the
ambulance already but when he got off
the plane
the pilots and the flight attendants all
wanted to have their cartogram done
that was amazing that was amazing
so so and before i let this thing go
because this is
this seems like it's it's out there but
it's re it's not approved by the fda yet
oh good point it is approved
it is approved for veterinarians right
yeah i don't know if does the
veterinarian's have an fda today
veterinarians can buy it
so there's a lot of savvy doctors
who are
veterinarians on the web and buying
these and then using them off label
basically right that's what i've been
getting from some physician emails to
that effect yes interesting so all right
so it's it's
we'll let that we'll let that go where
it goes okay but the other ones
okay so this one is kind of neat because
um yesterday you were talking about
glucose and diabetes so i'm wearing a
sensor like this which has a tiny 27
gauge needle you can be a hair thin that
gives under the skin in my abdomen you
can also wear it on your arm and so this
connects to the phone and every minute
get a glucose so if you turn the phone
on it's still 725 in california but
my glucose right at this moment is 98.
so it's non-invasive nine and well it's
very minimally invasive there is a tiny
but it actually is you feel it much less
than a finger needle
it's a prototype but what's nice about
this is you can go two weeks really
without any finger sticks it you can get
factory calibration
it appears to be amazingly accurate but
it's really in many ways
amazing impact on lifestyle yeah because
when you're holding your phone all the
time doing stuff and then you're seeing
your glucose every minute it has a big
impact on what you might eat yeah
because you don't really want to see
your glucose be shooting up and this is
the future this is a major i think a
vital sign that will be on our phones
before long i think it's pretty exciting
and it really does have a an impact on
your your activity uh your lifestyle you
learn about certain foods especially i
have learned that have a marked effect i
would never have predicted on on raising
glucose and and leaving to a kind of
durable hit to your eyelid cells of the
pancreas right so and the the last one
is a um
an ultrasound machine that attaches to
your phone right right so this one
i use in every patient i haven't used a
stethoscope in a patient since um
january 2010 when i got my hands on this
because why would i
listen to love dub which i was a big
proponent of that doing a lot of bedside
uh cardiology teaching but i said forget
that that that's history because this uh
basically takes the place of that
because you can do the entire heart exam
uh in a few seconds so i mean i can i
can show this to you i don't want to
take have you take off your nice tie and
shirt but i'll do that i'll do a scan on
my heart here just to show you how fast
this is done and how how much
information i got to put some gel on
here
which is a little group but um
and i promise i won't pull an anthony
weiner i know that i'm in new york city
um
but you see here's the uh ultrasound
and uh
and uh basically i what i can do is
um there's my heart heart muscle
and i don't know if you can see that but
that's my mitral valve my heart muscle
um right ventricle aorta aortic valve
the size of everything oh i see it i see
it yeah yeah and all that's gonna say i
was gonna say it's a boy
you you would say that now unfortunately
who makes that that's a ge that's a
that's available a nominal device which
i don't know why well actually i in a
way i do know why uh but it should be
part of the physical exam why should you
send patients to the formal echo lab
unless there's something structurally
really significant
we do over 20 million echoes in this
country 800 each
and most of them are unnecessary and not
only that but when we just we use a
stethoscope we did it's very relatively
non-informative right this should be
part of every physical exam and the
other thing is really phenomenal when
you can digitize a person's heart or
abdomen or wherever you're doing
ultrasound that is widely transferable
through wireless so you can have
somebody a paramedic in the field you
can have an emergency room doctor and
send these loops and can get interpreted
by an expert all you got to do is be
able to put this in the area of interest
and you're golden because you now are
getting this information
you know shared and that's i think
really a great step towards yeah all
right we have time for a couple
questions
i have one on twitter to start us off
our doctors and hospitals
oh
fair one are doctors in hospitals
fearing the loss of money through
technology empowered patients
are they feeling loss of money well the
empowered patient era hasn't really the
real one hasn't gotten roots yet i mean
that's actually really why i did the
book is trying to get that
moving forward because you know we're at
this point which i would describe as a
as a medical gutenberg whereas the
printing press in the 1400s changed
everything now we have smartphones and
tablets with all one's critical
information that is now in the hands of
consumers so when that really gets going
and people have their data that they own
as i agree with with rick yesterday
that's the the the shift that can occur
and that would really uh
propel this great inflection great shake
up in in medicine
all right couple questions up here
here comes the microphone
if you had a magic wand
what would you do it does have one okay
let's say the second one
what is and you walk into medical school
today
what would be the first thing that you
would change and tell the deans to do
well it's funny you asked that because
here in new york city mount sinai on the
first day of medical school
rather than giving out stethoscopes they
gave out these v scans to every medical
student and that was a sign of progress
but beyond that i mean the problem today
in medical school is i started a medical
school when i was in cleveland and this
is a 140 medical schools in this country
is there any curriculum that really is
uh into genomics today you know
contemporary genomics how about wireless
sensors how about you know this this
whole movement of what we're talking
about this morning so that has to change
and it's actually uh remarkably
difficult to change uh a medical school
curriculum it's kind of like changing uh
the medical community very resistant to
to those sorts of things but
that's what i would try to do is is
basically you know reboot uh education
uh and it's also you know still very
traditional with classes and the old way
of learning uh there's obviously a far
better way to do that today
there's another question right in front
kaplan
testing our kaplan
the bioethicist that who has escaped
from penn is now here in new york
has
always called behavioral health and
psychiatric conditions
the third rail of bioethics
where do you see or do you see any
intersect in terms of
genomics interacting with
psychiatric or
behavioral conditions and and in a way
of either addressing them or or
or managing them and monitoring them
well there's an amazing number of
interactions that you're bringing up
here like for example just in recent
weeks we learned that these new
mutations in sperm i mean in fact i
think craig touched on this just
barely but
that's
creating much
more as fathers age
neuropsychiatric diseases such as
schizophrenia autism intellectual
disability
we also by the way of biosensors have an
amazing ability now to quantify mood
through an aggregated way of not only
galvanic skin response but inflection
and tone of voice movement communication
you put all these things together you
can have exquisite
ability to quantify mood to follow
people for example with depression so
digitizing mental health
both with respect to genomic liability
as well as the physiologic
sensor world is really opening things up
and obviously this is a really important
area
we have time for one question
there was there was one thing um so we
have lots of gadgets and but one thing
we talked about that i wanted to make
sure we we touched on was this it's not
all gizmos and gadgets that you're
you're advocating um the the open notes
initiative was talked about which is
actually funded by rwgf but um but
describe that and the impact of that
well i think this is one of the most
important studies to come out in a long
time in terms of democratization of
medicine
and so what robert wood johnson did was
uh fund this open notes initiative now
for even though by hipaa you have the
right we have the right to request our
office notes nobody knows that and
nobody does it and physicians don't want
that to go out because they say hey i've
got in my note it's not about sob and
the patient may think i'm calling him an
sob when it just means shortness of
breath so the whole idea is oh my gosh
the patients would be terribly insulted
and confused you know i wrote obese or
whatever and so it turns out in the
study of
over 13 000 patients in three centers
seattle boston and geisinger
pennsylvania they showed a remarkable
impact of how good this was and in fact
the patients loved it and the physicians
who were doubting about it before going
in they loved it too so now every one of
those
individual patients in those centers are
getting this open note access and that's
the way it should be across the board
was there did they measure
improvement in health or was it they
measured particularly things like uh
adherence to medications about comfort
with their their uh their whole program
of their medical management
whether they were worried or confused
which was like one to eight percent
which is really low single digit numbers
between the three different centers
it was actually really remarkable and as
a wake-up call that why aren't we doing
this why don't we have the parity of
information
and and the respect for uh consumers
that that they deserve and this is just
part of that medical priesthood that
kind of analogous to the gutenberg story
which i think we have the opportunity
now
with this living by numbers and and
getting the information to the people
who deserve to have it who should own it
that's open notes has contributed nicely
to that right well dr topel thank you so
much for bringing us into the future
medicine thank you thank you
you